previously honored with a science and
technology award in 1994 for its
inventor Emmanuel Priven air the flying
cams latest version is the
battery-powered programmable sera 3.0
the flying cam sera 3.0 can go where
full-size helicopters cable systems or
other cameras support devices can it can
fly it can fly through a house with
exact and repeatable position Sara's
acronym which stands for a special
aerial response autonomous helicopter
it's a radio control and uses computer
assisted piloting with GPS assist for
the development of the flying cam sera
3.0 system the Academy is pleased to
present a scientific engineering award
to in manual craven air Yann Sperling
it's Han brandt and tony postie Oh
congratulations
well we were there 20 years ago in that
same nearly the same room for the
technical achievement award it was a
pleasure
my father was saying stop to play with
that you would go nowhere well and now
we are here again in the 21st century
with the challenge that many of us are
going through no digital age it's
changing everything and we succeeded
going through I'm not alone anymore
though we have a team now a family we
are very happy to be part of your family
for those people that awarded us the
scientist the Board of Governor because
it was a real challenge it was seven
years of hard work integrating a lot of
different technologies a lot of
different skills a lot of different
languages with people like Yan within an
engineer and behind the platform the
flying helicopter itself each and a
designer with drawing parts a thousand
eight hundred parts in the system we use
rapid manufacturing we use all those new
technologies that allowed to design
parts that are just in imaginable in the
past and we have a software engineers
developing the core of the system
the autopilot and we try to combine all
those technology in one unique system
thesaurus system and that challenge well
we went through you know long-lasting
significant and outstanding okay to
reach that you know you need your ma you
need your mother of course a new father
like you know that you need your wife as
soon as you reach that level you know
you have to count on your wife you need
to count on your kids that will not see
you as much as the other guys will you
need you count on your partners thanks
to family and mr. Victor mo for franca
international they made it up and this
is the producers those that are trusting
you and believe that you will succeed
and we thank you finally all of all of
you to be part of that new family we
have now in the 21st century going to
new challenging situation but with more
tools than ever and I would just want to
finish with one simple thing saying that
today we avoid you too you know you
heard about Voyager 2 where to to us
launched in 1977 1977 it's a it's a
satellite an unmanned space ship like us
is right now leaving the solar system is
the further is the system that was
developed by humankind that goes as much
as we can imagine today it has reached
the limit of the solar system still in
the movie industry to move a camera in
the air is still a challenge in the
close vicinity but we are trying to make
it happen and with all of us we will say
again and go like this alright keep
dreaming with us and fly with us thank
you very much